should we go hey welcome everybody
thanks for coming this was kind of a
last-minute thing this is probably a
little bit less of a panel and more of a
chatty talk we're just gonna hang out
for an hour and talk to you guys about
the behind the scenes just imagine a
fireplace there wait wait Mary can I
interrupt it this is a production panel
is everybody rolling you two are over
there we get on over there you got sound
we're good okay instead of a fireplace
imagine like a control room on fire
that's right some idealistic um we're
gonna go down the line just in case
there's a few new faces for anyone
probably me jairo my name is Rob
handlery i am a video producer at
gamespot i make um probably seen them to
grab some comparisons there are pre
predominant thank ya generate a lot of
high traffic when i'm not doing that i'm
making feature content for like anything
from GTA videos to the early access
games like daisy or anything like that
hey I'm Mary Kish I am also a producer
at gamespot I run a few of our live
shows including the lobby with Danny
O'Dwyer and Chris waters I also run a
few of our other live shows from time to
time we recently did like a live indie
feature and then I also do features just
like Rob does including new releases and
random features about any games I like
Drew Scanlon video producer giant bomb I
do a lot of things
that's too I Vinnie Carabella I spend
most of my days convincing people it's
hard to build a studio and then just
kind of play games and pretend we're not
up and running in Jason a striker Giant
Bomb um I do a lot of the stuff that
drew doesn't do all the Quick Looks and
stuff so whatever he doesn't want to do
that's me [ __ ] rolls downhill yeah well
I think a great way to start this off is
because people always do want to know
where you start with a studio and we
actually did have someone recently
decide to move pack up everything and
create a brand-new studio which is
amazing because you get to do it the way
you want and it's also a pain in the
butt and that was then II d-didn't in
New York I'd want hmm I did it in New
York yeah um yeah so it is a great place
to start when you have nothing so yeah
Alex and I moved to New York and we've
kind of actually switched offices twice
now so this will be the second studio
I've had to set up in New York it'll
probably be probably about the fourth or
fifth studio and I don't know a decade
or so put together and each time it's
fun because the technology changes so
rapidly so I would say to that the
biggest thing for anybody whether you're
just plugging in a webcam in your
computer or you're trying to do stupid
things like record gameplay with
high-end equipment and SDI stuff which
is just a waste of time know your
limitations from the start know what you
want to do right so in in New York I was
like let's let's do 1080p 60 guys over
and like you've been around a while yeah
it's been around a hardco be everybody's
doing it on the internet and YouTube and
all the youtubes are doing it yeah we
should do it this logitech webcam says
it does it so like let's just do it
uhhhh and it's not hard to do if you're
just by yourself it's actually
it's actually fairly easy you can do
with consumer pieces of equipment can
add media box or no gotta plug it in uh
but not all 1080p60 is the same like the
thing that I think gets lost or doesn't
translate over is what it's compressed
at right like in that and that's
actually a big thing and I don't wanna
go too much in the technical details but
it doesn't work for us and that just
became a nightmare and actually set us
back a lot while I was trying to build
that studio so I actually put my
expectations a little too high on the
studio and I've rolled it back to just
doing 720 and then I was like no this
1080p thing I look at these cameras and
it our cameras in their studio in San
Francisco don't do 1080p 60 so had to
get new cameras and then those didn't
work and then it was just a big
nightmare and I kind of I'm glad I did
it because we had to walk down those
steps but if I kind of scale back a
little bit things probably would have
gone a little more smoothly I don't
regret it but it you know it's one of
those things where know what your
deliverable is going to be and know what
you need to do to execute on it there's
no really like pc parts picker for
building a studio and saying that
everything is going to work together and
that's really scary and really hard
because the formats change constantly
and talk to Joey familiy about this a
lot just trying to keep all that
information in your head just sometimes
feels like it's gonna explode as things
constantly change and things have
changed a lot in the past decade Dennis
your question Mary yeah pretty much sums
it up yeah it's hard it's building from
scratch is super tough but also walking
into somebody else the studio kind of
sucks too so those the whole thing is
kind of a don't get into it just stop
stop doing it yeah I'd actually like to
hear Jason's perspective about walking
into our cable filled jungle so I
started my career as a were just doing
things independently from home so I used
a lot of those same kind of consumer
stuff so I had my own way of doing
things right and then I went to Game
Informer and they had a very small good
do department so I got the opportunity
to use some
our grade broadcast stuff but still I
was doing things the way that I knew how
to do it so do as I stepped on a giant
bomb though that's like somebody else's
house somebody else's kitchen it's like
everybody you know you you know that
they have forks and knives in the
kitchen you have no idea where they are
or how it all works so adhering to their
way of doing things was a big change for
Jason actually the blue spatula goes to
the left sorry sorry Bubba I'll get it I
swear not to the right of the pepper
grinder yeah that much but yeah I mean
everything good you know if any talked
about you know getting equipment to work
with one another you know when it does
it's it's a family but it's usually kind
of a dysfunctional family so some things
you know we're temperamental yet very
very temperamental so so at everybody's
studio i think is a very individual you
know think it's it's own little organism
and you got to treat it as such it's
funny is it we get a lot of comments
that are like why is it so damn hard for
you guys to get a video on the freaking
internet like people do it all the time
just plug your brain into the youtube
channel and just rate record and it is
actually that easy now it is actually
that easy to plug your el gato into a
computer put your gameplay in have your
USB microphone or USB microphone and
camera and do it that way like that is
not actually that hard turn on any
record your your mp4 you put it up
you're good your audio it can be in sync
or not I think that's though that's
always gonna be there to surprise it
gets hard when you have more than one
person it gets hard when you have more
than one camera and it gets hard when
you have to have a studio that's
flexible to have more than one like
console pc old game old game console
that's when things break and that's when
it gets super hard so think about having
one person who has a pair of headphones
on who's listening to just a gameplay
right that's easy you just put your
headphones into the computer the
gameplay is coming out of the computer
you got your webcam you're all set now
think of Jason there has headphones on
also now he has to hear me right so now
I have to have my audio coming out of
the headphones that means I need to hear
it back he needs to hear it back there
needs to be no delay because I'm hearing
my own voice coming back and then we
need to make sure that the gameplay is
not necessarily coming out of this
speakers so it's got to come out of the
headphones it just gets a lot more
complicated if your start switching
cameras and throw that into there that's
when everything breaks so stop working
with other people yeah and and have a
good time by herself yeah yeah we
recently did we did a quick look for
evolve and that required several people
also from New York office from our
office and we were all going through
PlayStation chat instead of in-game
checks in game chat sucks if you're
trying to record the quality goes down
and it we had everything pre-planned and
I think we still ended up recording an
hour past when we thought because people
kept dropping out there were problems
with audio left and right it did not go
smoothly and I think something that
people don't think about is nothing goes
according to plan ever when I'm ever
told that we're going to start shooting
it for I know it's a lie I know you're
lying to me and that's okay because this
is the kind of thing that happens when
you when you create the kind of you know
one that you're doing that kind of shoot
it's going it's gonna go wrong what was
your guys's experience coming into
gamespot a place that has been
entrenched in their own way of doing
things for over a decade gamespot's
going on almost 19 years old Wow yeah
you're an adult now okay and you know
there's a lot of changes when you go
into a company like that you know Rob
and I are actually a little fairly new
to the company and it only converted to
HD like less than five years ago so
you're looking at a company that adapts
to change a little slowly and you are
kind of pushing them into what you want
but if you want it not only do you have
to fight for it but you you have to
basically come up with it on your own
and almost all the things that we work
on we pioneer them and if they work and
nothing breaks then we're allowed to
keep doing it so you you know you want
to go get it but it
if it messes up you look like the idiot
now and that's a good testament to like
Rob working on his graphics comparisons
because those didn't really exist I mean
you wanted to do them and you just
basically started doing it it's
interesting how those kind of fanned out
like those were given to me you'll just
place my lap like we need someone to do
Assassin's Creed Black Flag grabs of
Harrison I remember doing it and you
know they're tricky but we only do them
because they just get so many damn views
it's insane you know hundreds of
thousands and and so those were as far
as I know how I kind of started picking
my own little battles to win was those
who started trafficking so well
especially with the new consoles right
everyone want to see what the hell a ps3
is compared to to be asked or is it
worth buying and those are still fairly
fairly a top dog as far as like you know
like how many views they generate and
that's what I'm doing now and what's
really cool is like myself like coming
in and just basically then I prior to
working at gamespy only worked at curse
for one year and working at gamespot I'm
given the graphs comparison I kind of
just turned in my own thing and how do
you put your own mark on something like
a graphics comparison you would think
it's just you know straightforward but
you what are you showing exactly right
like remember us I've seeing other
graphs in Paris ins the other day it's
like you know you get two people on
screen you're not going to show
basically a line down the middle of two
different people you're going to
basically move the line and you're going
to show Fanning and all sorts of moves
but it gets kind of just what you what I
developed over the years it's like what
do I want to see personally like and
those kind of just work out and so on
and I'd say the biggest challenges grabs
comparison is also like matching right
you start a game yeah you can compare
cutscenes and and pre-rendered stuff but
it's not really what you really want to
show we do want to show is like you know
actual gameplay so it's always
interesting to like develop a style and
you know it fit effectively and
efficiently too so of course you know
when I kind of figured out my own is
just like how do I show the same image
well I move really slowly when I do the
first level and then the gameplay he
gets when he does a graphics comparison
his absolute [ __ ] like he's not actually
playing the game he's turning the camera
around eight times until he gets
murdered by people he's running into
things that he knows will kill them he's
getting the limitations of it so you can
get the right shot a gameplay is
worthless it's not about playing the
game it's about getting the exact vision
that you want to show the differences in
trees that should be like 500 meters
away that's kind of like being a game
tester like when your game testing you
don't you're not playing the game you're
doing something completely different
right and it's it's crazy how mindless
it is too because I'm also doing it like
I mean the craziest when I did was you
know ps3 ps4 xbox 360 xbox one and then
pcl like over and over again and yeah
which here are the best graphics pc
normally takes it and not really
surprising well there you go but then
you also see like the really small
details of like an xbox one typically
has like really high contrast with
blacks and stuff like that but I will
say no matter what all the comments
that's ridiculous oh yeah right but it's
that's probably it it's the funniest
thing because it's just it's just pc
master brings Xbox fanboys [ __ ] you I
love that you said what do you want to
see that's something we all probably ask
ourselves a lot before we come up with
any ideas or what we're going to do it
honestly comes down to as simple as what
do I give a [ __ ] about what do I care
and when we make plans to produce the
lobby or when you guys are doing
unprofessional Friday's it's as simple
as a lot of times we are sitting there
in the office talking about something
you know maybe there's a trailer for
something we turn it on we put the
speakers up and everyone gathers around
like something really cool happen and we
watch it and then we just start talking
about whether or not we liked it and the
more we talk about it the more we
realize that the conversation we're
having
is already interesting we do anything
but we're already starting to dissect
the problem with something or why
something really succeeded and that
naturally when I realized that if we can
get two people to fight because they
disagree that's going in the show that's
good video yes always and we we're
constantly doing that like that's
something Danny picks up on really well
when we're when we're doing the lobby is
when people start talking about
something he hears that and he knows
that it's gonna it's going to go into
the next show and those are
conversations that you know we have when
we're looking for content so a lot of
times we were like why do you put the
things the particular things you have on
your show and I was a cool that's the
stuff we were talking about on Monday
and then that ends up being in the show
on Tuesday all right oh really
interesting too as far as like just how
you're bringing that up like the office
structure is so dependent on that like I
think of a cup just a typical typical
office with like cubicles and such like
that like there needs to be
conversations like continually
throughout the day or else there's this
dryness nobody wants drive video yeah
sausage quote right there right no dry
sausage chasing uh it's interesting what
Mary said about a conflict and I really
do think it might sound weird but
production is about it's about contrast
right contrast is interesting it's
interesting in life it's gonna be
interesting if you're setting up a shot
with lighting it's going to be
interesting when you're laying in your
music you're going to want dynamics you
want to go loud and low and loud and low
you're going to want people with
differing opinions nobody really wants
grays and neutrals and it's something to
keep in mind what if you're ever
planning or producing a show that people
react to different ends of the spectrum
is better than they do to just kind of a
flat line or vanilla line it's it's why
you look for contrast and lighting it's
why that stuff is so interesting it's
why people are I mean this is stuff you
learn when you're composing their shots
people are attracted to people's
eyeballs it's the most contrast
contrasting part of your face it's kind
of human nature and it kind of
philosophically runs through what people
are attracted to
content not that you should always have
we're not necessarily going for reality
TV and staging fights in the office but
need one huge [ __ ] to start fights
with everyone in this house are eggs
made I dad but but it's interesting and
at the same time I I do think everybody
on this panel and most producers out
there who work on a team our negotiators
you you negotiate constantly in an
office and this isn't going to be a
seminar negotiation but you have a you
know point based negotiation you have
interest based negotiation and Stanton
it holding to your point is not going to
get you anywhere right if you have a
video that you need to get up and trying
to badger your talent or your crew to
hit that date is not going to get you
anywhere and then you have interest
negotiation which is like what are we
trying to do what are we trying to
accomplish maybe I can be more flexible
on the time we record or maybe I can be
more flexible with what we record and
you really you just have to kind of be
ready to compromise with everybody it's
always going to be a compromise like
Mary said earlier nothing ever works out
perfectly so scale back if you can't
reach the goal of having the perfect
video you know make it the best video
you can within your budget get yourself
a goddamn good microphone first right
seriously then get a decent camera then
get some lights and and you'll be well
on your way to making good video and
then be ready to do a lot of
compromising and get a pretty good
computer she agreed like audio first
definitely audio first I mean it really
depends on what you're doing but think
of anything you've seen on YouTube that
is like the video quality is crap but if
you can't hear what the person saying it
doesn't matter you're just going to tune
out immediately when I used to scream
stuff years and years ago when i had
producer sitting on a couch watching
whenever they started tapping their foot
or looking away is where i would stop
and just make an edit point in my video
it's like just when they lost interest
and that's where i were trying to
introduce some contrast into it to kind
of get them back in whether that's a
hard cut or adding another music track
or something because as soon as people
start zoning out
I've lost them and that happens the most
I feel like when you can't hear what
people are saying okay when you're
talking about compromised something that
like immediately comes to my mind is I
believe that was something you guys
worked on Jason and drew when you're
working on something for Dan Reicher it
required a very particular setup we did
a little chute of it I don't think it
even scratched the surface of how much
[ __ ] they went through for like I think
just a few small hours and it was really
fascinating to watch them work that out
yeah we uh Dan Reicher wanted to beat
Mike Tyson mike tyson's punch-out
something he had never done 25 years of
playing mike tyson's punch-out so he's
like all right well I've tried many
times so we could probably get a couple
weeks of content out of this if you just
sent me up in a room and I just play
over and over and over again because
yeah we actually attempted at Game
Informer we recorded three straight like
hour-long sessions no luck whatsoever so
we thought we were gonna have like a
gold mine of content yeah weeks we rape
stuff dan just go off into this room and
do a live stream but it didn't work out
that way well the best was drew came
over and he's like I could get some
games white guys till I can't pump Dan
up and everything like that and we all
showed up and were like watching we're
like [ __ ] I got stuff to do hang around
and we literally walked away and B and
then he did it look same day so so like
turn Jason why was it so hard why
couldn't you just plug in Nintendo in
the to youtube and stream it ah well I
mean when you're when you're dealing
with like an old nes game first of all
it's really hard to capture puts out
like 240 be most those things are like
in a for Eddie on up that's that might
be too technical but Dan really wanted
to play this on a CRT so there was no
like input lag so to indicate we wanted
to reduce every single excuse stand
could give yep all right we're gonna
give you an NES plugged into a CRT with
D if you can't do it it's your own fault
but he also wanted what we thought that
he was going to be spending hours and
hours upon this and we didn't want to
like you know take it to a studio so we
tried to set up just a really easy setup
you know laptop webcam
and you know it's the real cheap capture
unit also something that bypassed
everything that we were currently using
to do other contents so it would be nice
to have Dan just go do this thing while
we were also recording another quick
look exactly independently yeah so
you've got your console you got your nes
you're not splitting the signal with
like a navy splitter yep powered amp
that's pushing on to the CRT so what's
your other signal going into so our
other signal had to be converted to 720p
okay so you have a scan converter in
line yes okay and then you've got Dan on
a microphone down on a mic how are you
getting that audio into that converted
NES video stream so the audio from Dan's
Mike goes into a mixer and then the
audio from the NES goes into the same
mixer it doesn't go into the CRT okay
and then Dan gets from the mixer a
headphone out of his voice and the game
at the same time that same mix also goes
into our box that the video signal is
going into so everything's going into
that one thing and getting married
together getting married together and
then that's what's getting screamed out
and that's what's getting recorded yes
got it simple simple are you right no
problem I should also mention that to
get a 240 signal into 720p also not that
he's not not even know it's it's 240 240
progressive is not a real video standard
no you don't look on a box nothing
nothing you buy really is like yet I
understand what that is but there are
things out there like the framemeister a
super expensive piece of equip on Google
I try not to get a virus when you go to
the web page exactly I mean you buy it
from Japan basically yeah its import
only does an amazing job with like you
know line doubling and stuff like that
we're gonna get one eventually but yeah
we ads you alright so we took the 240
bignell a signal we sent it into you
like a sony like hand cam type thing
yeah and that'll like standardize it to
480 which we can then bring into
something else and then go up to 720 and
yes like this guy here this this is a
scan converter thing that my microphone
is sitting on my microphone that is
sitting on this eight thousand dollar I
assume probably around there
similar to what we have a thousand
dollars to change a signal into another
signal and have it be something that
does an artifact that you don't have a
lot of delay on that it keeps the color
space correct even that the one we have
will not take in a 240 pieces something
like an al gato those things are like
two or three hundred bucks because they
are expecting a very specific video
signal that's coming from an Xbox or
Playstation when you get into weird
stuff like a Nintendo that they just
kind of made up a video signal like
that's why things are so expensive
anyway yeah my question the whole thing
with Dan is Mike Tyson thing at the end
of the video I'd look incredulous
because like I spent all this time
setting up the room and you meet it in
one day but I I couldn't have been
happier with how that went because we we
spent all that time setting up and
testing and making sure that everything
went well for the week prior to that
because I knew that that was a
possibility that Dan could be to do one
day and I wanted to make sure that
everything worked correctly because we
were only going to have one shot at it
and everything worked great yeah how
many how many redundancies do you guys
have in San Francisco for recording
quick looks um about three yeah so we do
a our primary recording is a real time
mp4 in code that we trim and then upload
to the site sometimes quick upload
because it's already compressed we also
record directly to a final cut pro
machine that records in pro res and then
we also do a record to a solid state
hard drive that is also in pro res how
many times is one of those fail one of
those fails
five times a year I'm on a record on a
record all three of them seem to fail
about three times a year yeah definitely
weird i don't know what you guys do you
guys do redundancy when you're recording
stuff yeah we always especially lively
record to a pix as well which I found to
be a really wonderful universal tool
it's a little it's basically a box about
this big with an LCD screen on it that
takes a SDI and hdmi and it's pretty
awesome yeah it works um it does
8-channel recording which is why I love
it so much so I can basically take this
little cube it looks like a steam
machine it's really really dense and I
can basically take that to anything plug
in a game typically HDMI is all we have
and if they have anything else I go what
the hell are you doing give me an hdmi
and then I can record to audio channels
in addition to that all on separate
audio channels so that when I'm editing
it in Premiere you the voices that i'm
recording are not on the same channel as
my gameplay so if something goes wrong
and i need to cut it i can literally cut
out any voices without getting into my
gameplay change volume levels that's
right the control that you can have is
just it's wonderful and those are the
kinds of things that we look for we have
but yo my god and we we record at least
two one extra and we have about the same
success rate the pic yeah the pics is
about this big and you put an SSD in it
and you can bring that to an event and
if you have like a breakout you can get
mikes in it and you can get an hdmi
signal in or SDI c'est bon bini what
what did that look like 10 years ago so
10 years ago that was a crate that was
about maybe half the size of this with a
like a BBC HD deck in a tape a bunch of
scan converters in it maybe a laptop or
something like that and we wheeled those
around Santa Monica for that III I had a
crate that was on wheels strapped to my
back with rope
rolling it up and down the pier to event
it was terrible it was horrible uh but
the picks up you know it's funny like
going from component to HDMI some stuff
is really good some stuff is not so good
the digital handshaking with hdmi
devices can sometimes be really weird
especially with like Apple devices like
an iPhone there's a lot of this not
working yeah now it works like at least
with component stuff of the analog
signal like you had degradation and an
analog signal and you kind of like ah
the cables broken the jack is broken
like the hdmi stuff to do it's voodoo
you just power off and power back on and
you don't know why it's not working
there's a auto-detection for resolutions
from devices so like if you have
something in line that's doing a scan
conversion it'll be like oh I think I
know what you want it's like you don't
you really don't know what I want so
since stop changing my god damn video
signal I need to start a show 40 minutes
ago it's but some stuff is great the
embedded audio is good being able to
just walk into an event with one box and
not you know even as recent as like two
or three years ago we just have a bag
that had a whole bunch of adapters and
cables and component cables but now
everybody's kind of hdmi so that that is
better though even these pictures were
getting out date right I mean 1080i 727
on mmm this is so interesting the pics
also doesn't uh it doesn't record audio
if you don't have a video feed which
screwed you over once when you were
recording oh yeah an event was I sure
was recording but um I had to get the
dev commentary and it because
unfortunately you have to have a video
signal going in and I basically had to
have the dev play record them on the
pics and then rerecord the gameplay
separately and they just did not like
that it was theirs so how many how many
of you guys here have done the interview
where you know three two one coming in
and then about 10 or 15 seconds in
realize you were not recording a source
oh ffs initely
yeah how many of you own up to it or say
yeah let's just take that again that's a
bad start you messed up I'm gonna say
anything that happens cuz that's the
goatse I think we could do that better I
think we could take that a little better
you guys are great let's just do that
again god damn it it's all me something
happen to me you know yeah sounded great
like it was like the first couple months
I was working at whiskey media we were
shooting something for comic fun I can't
remember what it was but Ethan Lance
threw himself down a flight of stairs
and I wasn't recorded so I said let's
get an alternate angle haha yeah who's
not easy and the audio stuff is probably
the trickiest too and it's funny for her
video thing audio plays so much of a
role and what you're doing and a lot of
times even recording panels like this
you have a wireless kid over there
you've got a wireless kid on the camera
sometimes it was probably see why i drew
and Jason unwrapped 50 feet of XLR cable
they are prone and Joey and I was just
talking about this antennas get bent on
wireless kids they get staticky and it's
just like you're doing a live thing
you're recording it and suddenly you're
just listening there and your talents on
screen doing this thing and it's just
stole that did not it all happened last
night and the panel this is why
redundancy is so important he had you
know a direct line for the mixer going
into one channel on the camera we had a
shotgun mic you know just for you know
the room just in case the mixture
screwed up but we also had a zoom
plugged in like we do right now just
recording straight audio as well both of
the audio ports on the camera blew out
last night so your camera yeah yeah I'm
my camera so 30 seconds in did that
exact noise and I'm like oh [ __ ] and you
can't salvage that there's nothing you
can do so I quick ran over made sure
that our third backup was actually
working and yeah so I was also had a
wireless kit coming from the board to a
wireless receiver on my camera and I was
also recording a boom mic so currently
right now there are two clean sources
the zoom
and my camera redundancy is super
important yes and what it's just one of
those awkward things that it's part of
the part I like least about production
stuff is the like you know hey you know
your mic is rubbing on your shirt but
you guys are in the middle of something
here how do I get out there and
pantomime like this to somebody because
you or like your big huge beard is
rubbing on something and like I don't
know what to do I don't want to stop
this it's like II everything is always
fine in your audio check and it's always
fine all the cameras work and all the
gameplay works five minutes before you
start and then as soon as you start
somebody gets up takes myself go to the
bathroom comes back and suddenly it's
like they don't have it on it's in their
pocket or something it's also like a mic
check voice can be different for sure
making me a mic recording voice yeah oh
yes my Mic Check one two three one two
three awesome coming in three two one
hey everybody we're looking yeah yeah
we're always doing especially when it
comes to live you know in the lobby when
there's Mike issues when a game is ready
to play but all of a sudden its sides
not to and we're like cutting to a very
particular camera angle that we know is
high enough that I can like crawl on the
floor and you'll hear me uh you'll very
rarely you should ever see it but every
once in a while what's actually
happening behind camera is I'm doing
this the Danny knows to keep talking and
I'm messing with people while they're
talking and they're having a conference
just a one-shot on Danny right that's
right and he might be having to ask them
a question you might have to and so
they're answering and I'm saying I
answer them handsome Ethan and I give
them their little Mike and I make them
talk and there's a weird level of
professionalism that you have to have
when there's so much weird [ __ ]
happening there's a guy bent over
there's an ass right in your face and
you have to be talking about the game
that just came out and they're plugging
cables in and I'm you know cussing like
a sailor in the background I'm fixing
mics and then we run off like it never
happened
and I think that's something that really
happens with this is that there's a lot
of effort in making it look effortless
right if you see if you see the seams
then you've done it wrong yeah unless
you're intentionally ripping the fabric
apart and then you probably see the
seams yeah it's it's sweaty and
stressful and like you know it's
partially really good talent on the
other side of the camera like you I
cannot say this enough having good
people on the other side makes our jobs
hundred percent easier and I think we've
been really lucky all of us here to work
with really exceptional talent and then
on the other side it's you know sweat
and blood literally sweat and blood I
remember we were starting to show and
everything was all set we were like five
seconds away from pulling the fader bar
down and there was a guess it now I'll
get you a beer I gotta get a beer and
take the top off and the top of the
bottle broke and the my hand ran down
the bottle and it just took me a second
to sit there and be like work this out
in my head like all right I've got like
two seconds to start the show but blood
is going to start coming out in one
second and I just ran to the kitchen and
like rolled my hand up in a paper towel
ran back into the control room el mode
the bar to start the show meanwhile like
just blood starting to come down my arm
and like ran back in the kitchen while I
was like a show Jeff hey everybody and I
was running back and forth between the
kitchen like putting band-aids on my
finger and like running over and trying
to hit the button to switch a shot and
running back and forth uh and you know
that's one of those things it's just
like what are you gonna do there's
nothing to do and the show must go on
and it does and it's fun and we wouldn't
do it if it weren't fun and it's a
challenge and I love every day of it
except for the days I don't check
questions yeah let's open it up to
questions there's a mic like in the
middle of the floor
basically there's really not a lot of
rules here you have a question anybody
want to talk about genlock just get up
on the mic just just get real close to
it hey guys go get closer I tell people
uh who uh who I give a stick Mike to
like an ice cream cone like that close I
got it um so I do a lot of video
production for a YouTube channel that I
run and I actually have a framemeister
the thing you're talking about before
and it is awesome it's amazing right it
was like we did like a fundraiser with
our fans with like a marathon livestream
we raised like eight hundred dollars for
new equipment and the framemeister was
400 and I thought that was gonna be it
and then like that does like RGB scart
so I was like oh yeah it's car cables
now Jesus look $35 cables i ended up
using all eight hundred dollars and
stuff and I thought the video looks
amazing but of course liking it's not
like anyone watching a commented local
video so much better like so i guess
like my question is like cuz i just
obsess about video quality but no one
but besides me care so i was wondering
like what's the most amount of money
that you've sunk into like the smallest
amount of increasing quality man so it's
an addiction like especially when i was
doing this kind of on my own as a hobby
you know as an enthusiast it's like you
start off really small just like an
elgato or something like that and maybe
a webcam but man it exponentially
increases you know especially if you're
really into it so yeah all of a sudden
you're plunking down five hundred
dollars on some like dumb scan converter
that you really don't need but yeah
easily a thousand dollars on like you
know mixers and stuff like that just for
just for at home you know it's it's
addicting and it's I'm sorry my wife
video clicks is super expect like this
little this little fuzzy thing on here
I'll pull it off that's probably fine I
like 40 bucks like I'm not kidding well
windscreens are on lavaliers those
things are like 20 bucks it's like I
make that at home i'm at my son could
make that thing i know thats they
overcharge not overcharge yeah bless him
I don't know they charged with thing I
gotta do like the mics that we have at
home are like this big but we use a
little ball windscreens on because
they're like two dollars but if you get
the ones that are this big they're like
$45
because they know that you wanted the
the blue Yeti great mic for home use I
recommend that one for the quality is
fantastic on it and you know it's like
107 bucks USB mic if anybody's doing
stuff at home we have a spit guard on a
mic that was like 80 bucks it just
catches spit it's a net thanks guys yeah
you got thank you hey guys I was just
curious like um because a lot of you do
not only the production but you are
sometimes you have to take the role of
the talent you're obviously in front of
the camera a lot do you find that like
um you're more conscious of like the
things that are going on like making
icons with camera and audio because you
have been on the Talon so much of it and
like in charge of like cutting and all
that other stuff yeah for sure I
remember the first interview I did yeah
it was was it halo it was a halo yeah
interview David Ellis yeah reach I think
uh uh reach event yeah so it was you're
right it was a lot of like well I know I
know exactly how I want how I would edit
this so I know how I want to ask my
questions and and do I contacts and
stuff but then as soon as the light
turns on all that like goes out the
window right and then you're just stuck
with like oh no I don't have a question
he's going to stop talking and I have a
question and that's when your respect
for the guys who do the interviewing
goes way up yeah yeah it's like the
service industry anyone who's ever been
a waitress or something and all of a
sudden you know not to be rude to those
people because that's a hard job all of
a sudden you look around you know we've
just started you know where it's just
incredibly hard you look at someone who
pulled a cave pulled a giant thing up a
hill with a rope on his on his chest you
say well you know hats off to you your
perspective changes greatly yeah I think
more than learning or making your cut
better it's it's learning how to
interact with the other side of the
camera
like Drew is saying you really realize
what's kind of going through somebody's
head what they're worried about what
their interests are you're focused on
your audio and video like I said you're
wearing up somebody's scraping audio
whatever they don't care they're worried
about what their next question is the
word about listening with one ear
thinking with thinking with their other
here and that's really hard and like
Drew said that soon as you're on the
other side of the camera and you realize
when that light goes on and realize oh
right yet no now everybody's kind of
looking at me to do this yeah you sort
of realized as a producer like what you
what you what you shouldn't tell them
like what what is it should not be any
of their concern like in in cases of
like hey if I give you the signal adjust
your mic that's not their job like it's
your job to make sure it's right up the
first time and I will say it's really a
lot people think about it anymore but uh
if you get outside of the gaming
industry and outside of kind of reality
television there are places where people
shoot video and other people edit video
and I think being an editor or a shooter
and doing both that make sure your
product a lot better oh it's you know
total yeah I would even say you know
getting like dev commentary a lot of
times you don't know who you're
capturing and it turns out it's a guy
who speaks barely any English and you
sit there and you let him do his spiel
and then you would say that that was
great thank you so much perfect
everything went great and you go back
the office and you go we're doing
impressions piece here what everyone
listen to this yeah when you know what
to shoot you'll know like if you're not
an editor you might just spend like you
know I got the shot of this puddle or I
got the shot of this cloud it's [ __ ]
rad I got the shot of this you know
dudes head and then when you're an
editor you realize I need to get the
shot of that puddle for 15 seconds I
need heads and tails on it or this whip
pan is never gonna work when this guy at
so I I think actually taking on every
role will always make your product
better and I have a bit of empathy for
everybody that's involved mmm awesome
thank you yeah
hey guys um I was just wondering if
there's a funny behind-the-scenes story
about the Giant Bomb GDC 2014 video the
one where he had a party going on the
background and jeff gerstmann and phil
fish were passing around a bottle
buckfast yeah that's one where I sliced
my hand open oh oh oh yeah sorry yeah
sorry I think I think you weren't there
you were somewhere I don't know where I
was yeah you were somewhere you were
with Patrick me the trip yeah uh you
worst you were somewhere that's the one
where I cut my hand open yeah that's
that was enough for me okay okay you
work uh to that note I will say if you a
responsible producer you have to have
fun but you have to keep in mind some of
that stuff and giant bomb has been walks
a line between the goofy stuff and
making sure that we make a safe fun
environment for everybody so you know if
things do or somebody you know we're not
always the best at it but it's something
we think about like just need to turn
off like in all honesty like this is
something that is it we don't want
anybody to get hurt or we don't want
anybody to get too intoxicated and it's
something we think about I was I was
there remember I was there for fun I
wasn't doing anything I was having a
beer with everyone at the party and um
so what let's do who's recording was you
Jason somebody was like it all the
voices from the people having so much
fun in the background we're picking up
on the mics so I had to be the big jerk
to wrangle everyone up and say I know
you guys do have a really good time
we're gonna move into this dark cold
room over here if you could all follow
me I was there yeah I'm
thanks Mary yeah that lame person so
that the audio was better that was me
yeah uh thanks that's all I got thank
you hello okay um so you went through
all that stuff to get the NES to capture
properly for Dan's Mike Tyson fight for
things like the Retron that actually
just output to hdmi how much is the
noticeable is there a noticeable
difference between running it on a
retron that will just give you an hdmi
output there is some video conversion
going on you know and it's it's not an
exact replica of the hardware so some
people can notice a little bit of input
delay some people can't I'm in the camp
that really can't see it too much but
once again we did not want to give Dan
any excuses well a funny thing is dan
went to a bar a few days after this and
played it on an HDTV and beat him there
too so it was all mental yes so
sometimes when you're doing the live
streams it seems like you're using
retron and it's going ok and it works
perfectly ok I'm trying to do some
capron stuff and that is the super
easiest way to do it absolutely if you
talk to a speedrunner they will probably
laugh at you yeah they need original
software they need to CRT but you know
for general purpose stuff no only the
Retron when I've had problems with is
the audio the digital audio coming up
and I think sometimes flake out yeah I
think you guys strip it out right yeah
we strip out the audio make it analog
and then ingest it that way all right
thank you hey guys YUM so after talking
about when you're all the work you put
in to try and maintain professionalism
on camera when you're messing around in
the back just trying to keep everything
from burning down completely what sort
of when you're just a viewer is most
cringe-worthy to see other people not
work to correct basically I'm thinking
of like let's say it's a nun profession
Friday before a holiday weekend and Jeff
is sitting in the back with the
switchboard right there looking at it
like he wants to wear it like a quitar
like eating on camera it was it yeah
that's a big yep you got any time
watching something I see somebody eating
on camera I've been there everybody
unless you're wearing headphones you
don't realize it yep and then somebody
from the sides like hey check out this
new bag of chips and I'm like ah [ __ ] oh
yeah he open at all right turn everybody
down yeah that's mine they're like this
all right clapping on my that's a tough
one we're laughing right yeah yeah no
laughing on Jen mom said some people are
lies with their mic checks you say I'll
just give me a little bit of levels so I
can get your levels right and I go okay
I've talked about like this mm-hmm then
you go live well hey how's the gun in
the back fixing it that happens all the
time that and when people talk over each
other is the number one rule I always
try to avoid um I think Danny was taught
me this you say 101 no one ever talks
over anyone else you're not that
important everyone be quiet when someone
else is talking you wait your turn
because when it's muddled nobody can
hear anybody and all points are lost
nobody wins side conversations get real
rough it's it's again it's audio like
audios such a big part of it and when
you're sitting on a couch and you have
like ten people there and you're not
talking and the you know Rob merrier
talking you know and I'm talking with
Jason over here but we're miked and
could all the except we should bro
that's what a microphone does you know
it picks up everybody but you don't
realize it when you're sitting there
yeah or especially like our set
sometimes you get two people removed
back by that pc yeah and because it's a
physical separation you feel like you
can just have that conversation it's a
really hard habit to break when you're
like the people sitting there but what
do I always think about is how cool this
looks
yeah like we're like we're having a cool
conversation you came in here it's the
thing about that next I'm gonna cross
done thank you all right thank you very
much thank you hey guys i'm pat hello
Pat hi uh so I'm really lucky in that I
trick somebody into paying me to do
video for a living Congrats it's in a
Content area that I really care very
little about have you guys ever been in
that position and if so sort of how do
you keep yourself doing your best work
when you're not really super into the
stuff that you need to do mmm that's
it's super tough one of my old gigs was
traveling around running like in rooms a
lot like this I would record seminars
and they were all for like you know
medical industry accountants and stuff
that [ __ ] really boring I thought I was
gonna get super lucky one day cuz that
seminar was gonna be about breast
feedings I'm like yeah boobs all day
long turns out breastfeeding boobs the
crack and they bleed and stuff it's not
fun at all i would say ninety nine
percent of the time i did not enjoy any
of those but i enjoyed what i was doing
like from a technology standpoint so
it's you know you have to focus on that
part of the job i guess and less about
the content so you know if you're not
passionate about you know what you're
shooting be passionate about how will
you present it and go about it that way
I can't even say maybe thanks slipping a
little bit of you somehow and in that
like look back and be like god I kind of
got away with that shot you know I mean
like I showed some guy picking his nose
just for a brief second and no i don't
know i love doing that sometimes yeah
easter eggs yeah you say yeah throw a
little dutch tilt on this shot of this
task get get real cray i think we have
one more one or two more questions Oh
Kate let him go until they they tell me
now yeah oh one more question guys so I
have a question about a live
broadcasting come talk to us after
out there like legitimate not yo you
know so so um obviously in a controlled
setting where you have like a laptop and
an Ethernet connection or you're at home
or whatever and you can control like the
live broadcast feed and your internets
good and things like that great but you
know I sometimes in dealing with audio
and video in a live setting where I'm
trying to do a broadcast but you know
you're not necessarily have a decent
Wi-Fi or you know you guys what do you
guys do in terms of redundancy ensuring
like quality signal broadcasts talking
just for bandwidth um you know for
bandwidth um in a live production like
live streaming how do you how do you
compensate for random bandwidth like
we're in this room we got an Internet
drop how do we get yeah yeah if you're
streaming or like for example you're
doing a show or a concert or something
and you're trying to get it a live
stream up and yeah I would guess to the
best person to talk to about that I can
guarantee the guy I would always talk to
about that it's probably dammit auric uh
he knows that stuff inside out he works
at gamespot and they do line checks they
do quality of service checks before they
go down they get guaranteed but and if
it doesn't meet their needs they bring
in an outside service aunt dan would be
perfect it's a shame he I know there was
a time where we didn't expect to have
the amount of people viewing that we did
and I don't mean like 10 times I mean we
had so many viewers that it broke down
and so we had to get an outside vendor
in immediately and we paid for it and I
mean paid for I mean money it was
expensive to get a last-minute hitch in
and that started a chain of events that
now we consider heavily beforehand what
we estimate the audience to be and then
we double that so that are you handling
the streaming like directly from from
your service or you are you
sending the stream to another service
which is then sending it to all your
users or we send it to an outside server
outside service yeah they are they like
super expensive yes yes so you're
probably just dealing with like twitch
or something like that correct yeah yeah
it can be cost prohibitive at that point
like you might just have to take what
you can get the the bringing an outside
service can be expensive but here's a
here's even when you bring in an outside
service we had I think it was also Santa
Monica doing an e3 broadcasting
microwave I think our signal out and all
of a sudden live stream went out and we
just could not figure out what the hell
happened it would somebody kind of cable
with a lab and somebody had a UPS guy or
FedEx guy parked the truck in front of
the microwave dish and we had to push
that away like so sometimes even
bringing an outside service doesn't
always work but there are quality
outside service guys I've always been
impressed with the guys gamespot use
okay it's it's hard though that's a hard
thing relying any time like Jason was
saying those things are you come in and
you come into an event even if you're
filming breastfeeding or whatever we
relying on somebody else's
infrastructure is tough or even like
especially if you're doing a for example
our live stuff that we do at e3 like a
location that you are going to later
that you can't like readily go to like
if it's in another city like I can't
overestimate how important it is to for
you to physically go there to get
someone to physically go there and to
set out the internet like they can tell
you oh yeah we got we got 50 up no do
you you have to test that do you guys do
any kind of like cellular broadcasting
is that's another option to you that's
kind of a redundancy so if you do in
this room home and you're dealing with
would twitch I mean there's lots of
tools where you can check you know each
of the individual servers but it's also
not a bad idea to have like a 4g kind of
hotspot connection as well to use as a
backup in that case and also along the
redundancy line make sure that you're
recording locally somehow as well so you
can get it up if the stream does go down
43 we bring in our own satellite truck
salt so that we don't make I'm gonna get
right on that yeah yeah we don't mess
around money dorman she's on that switch
money yeah taking donations after the
after the break all right I think we're
probably at time right thank you thank
you thanks guys thank you
you